jetzt kommt zu einer neuen folge leute
wir sind heute in düsseldorf und haben
ein ganz besonderes schätzchen hier
hinter uns stehen das ist 1 991 in der
video genau ist das auto von w v leute
jetzt können wir das ist kein geheimnis
mehr 99 1.2 carrera 4 gts
[Musik]
damit werden heute nach unten drehen mag
ich freue mich sehr dass du zugestimmt
aber gerne richtig richtig liefer und ja
ich will eigentlich schon schnell ins
auto um leute ist nämlich ein bisschen
so was haben wir denn drauf pirelli
sottozero das war es einst autos so
fehlerfrei und das war ich leider selber
also ich hätte es gern auf meiner
schwester oder meine frau geschoben dass
sie das waren aber das war leider ich
wenn man auch nicht normal gewesen habe
man muss aber auch sagen die felge
schaut auch gut aus schon sehr anfällig
305 war die herren gerade drauf die
musste ich schon wechseln das ist der
zweite satz ist noch winterreifen das ja
ja ja genau weil es otto ist sind die
mütter reifen von pirelli nee stimmt
also die also ich hab musst du dir
tatsächlich wechseln jetzt ja ist schon
schick ich habe auch gerade eben zu max
gesagt übrigens hinter der kamera sind
alles schon richtige lachse in havanna
sucht so breit auch geworden das war
bereits so flach das ist schon richtig
sexy also ich finde ich nur noch sagen
das kannst du auch gut zu deiner liebe
leute welches outfit passt besser zu
diesem vorgehen damit einmal abstimmen
in den kommentaren ich heute besser
schluckt er mag ein bisschen lesen
ja ich finde halt das auto brauche nicht
viel dafür entschieden habe es einfach
so hat es halt ein bisschen rockiger
beim gts ja genau
und auf der einen seite immer noch ein
gentleman auto irgendwo auf jeden fall
porsche ja auch eine sehr sehr gute
spagat zwischen sportlichkeit der anders
statement ja dann sehen wir was 20 zoll
hinten 20 2 vorne auch sonst erfordert
ja auf jeden fall sehr sehr sehr sehr
schönes autor wir uns natürlich ganz
klar vorne der kofferraum und ich würde
sagen wir steigen ins auto rein du
fährst mich eine runde um stilfragen
werden und dann alles klar
er läutete den super rallye wird sagen
die 100 die erste frage dabei ist immer
was bedeutet autos für dich ja genau
die erste frage war was bedeuten autos
für dich also eigentlich
ich habe jetzt keine riesen verbindung
zu diesem auto thema halt
kindheitserinnerungen die mich zu der
marke getrieben haben das heißt seitdem
seitdem ich denken kann hat mein vater
immer ein
vager hinweis sehr aus mainz 88 und ich
da machen wir mit abgeholt und so und
das war so eine sache die mir im kopf
geblieben ist und von daher das
erstrebenswerte bei mir war erhalten
immer diese marke ich wollte immer
natürlich andere andere hersteller sind
vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
extrovertierter ich da geht nicht dass
ich auch mal was anderes fahren werde
aber mein herz schlägt schon für diesen
markt und zwar ich kam das daher ja dass
das kindheitstagen mike porsche gefahren
das ich halte diese marke das sind wir
so gefällt aber sonst hat das keinen
wunsch stellen ich habe jahre lang immer
meinen 946 gefangen
die solideste und es dort so es gibt ja
gold sechs silber und ihre anhänger
aufgefordert meine mum früher aber
branche ist hat auch porsche ist hat
porsche das ist eine sache die begegnung
immer wieder bei diesem thema sehr sehr
viele jungs junge männer männer und drei
frauen natürlich auch in deutschland
haben einfach eine besondere bindung zu
das verbindet sehr viele sachen ist sehr
alltagstauglich wären nur die andere
mannschaft vom bundestag ende fährt man
hier denkt man hier den spagat wird
inzwischen nimmt immer halt sport beim
wenn man auf gewisse sachen achtet
aufhält stabil
wert erhalten ja und universell
einsetzbar also wie ist der
zwischenstand so also der zwischenstand
wir haben einmal alles bearbeitet was es
an themen geben kann was man zu
bearbeiten überhaupt gedenken könnte und
jetzt kommt der letzte punkt der
bearbeitung dass ich diese wunderschöne
flunder
dadurch muss sagen ich höre ich fahre
ich hinterher ich höre die ganze zeit
über lokale das habe ich mal gefragt wie
das so ist wenn man es braucht also
deutlich merkbar film aber jetzt nicht
sehr angenehm wenn man wenn man sage
jetzt nicht übertrieben erklärt also
dann okay leute ich weiß es
allerspätestens ich wusste vorher
schauen aber jetzt von dem von lukas
branche weiß ich auch links genau
richtig weißt du denn warum das da ist
ja wegen der motorsport verbundenheit
und früher war die schlösser links warum
motorsports die autos die wurden halb
gestartet beim rennen und anschließend
also derjenige war halt so am steuer und
so weiter und dann haben hat der aus dem
technik team das auto gestartet und hat
dann ein ordentlich abgezogen so war das
okay
und es wurde auf jeden fall das auto
wurde von jemandem gestartet der sich
nicht im fahrzeug befindet und so war
das bin ich jetzt mal gespannt
andiamo da ganz okay max film schon da
muss ja nichts mal direkt
geil geil geil da es richtig giftig er
ist richtig giftig das macht spaß das
ist schon lustig auf jeden fall
haha ja die ja ja ja ja die lenkung ist
jetzt alles noch mal neu eingestellt
dass ich sehr genau
mega genau also gefühlt es ist schwer zu
beschreiben du hast das auto springt
nicht hin und her wenn du das lenker
bewegt aber du hast auch nicht gefühl
dass dann nichts was hier zum die mit
herz mal dem das härtere fahrwerk
einstellen das wirst du dann schon
merken gerade beim thema boden werden
wir da wo wir gerade lang gefahren sind
das ist dann schon sehr britisch also
ich hoffe ja oft mit dem fahrwerk fahre
ich sehr ungern auf der autobahn zum
beispiel da bin ich wahnsinnig mit den
ganz harten aber gerade eben mal so mit
dem normalen gediente fahrwerk war es
wirklich okay komfortabel
ich schaue mit dem lange strecken hin
und zurück also ich hab gar keine
rückenschmerzen oder sonst wem hast
einfach mega geil wird zur selber auch
noch porsche fangen also jetzt oder ist
es kein grail so dass auf jeden fall
noch porsche ist für mich so schon so ja
ich habe jetzt geschafft irgendwie
vorher also mehr als es irgendwie also
kann ich also ziehe schon immer auch so
lebenssituation mit autos so rolls royce
ist so ja okay wir sind industrie erben
großindustrie dann hunderte von
millionen und und was geht gar nichts
mehr verständnis in pvp ferrari ist so
ja ich finde das geil habe das geld auch
relativ neue würde ich sagen sollte
jetzt sowieso und forscher ist so der
verschafft neuer porsche ist okay alles
gleich mit erfolgreicher anwalt das so
ja weil wir löschen und dann einmal
geld das nicht trauen das ist stramm
kann man aber mal machen glaube ich das
okay war
hier müsste man mit auf so einem
testgelände von hp kommen
da geht es richtig los ich war mir nicht
sicher ob du jetzt hier in vier oder
fünf jahren also antrieb oder nicht und
ich dachte okay wenn er bei der
heckantrieb hat fragst du in deiner
unternehmer dürften kannst damit hat
sich das ja dann kann man natürlich auch
einmal in das geht schon das geht schon
gut es natürlich schwieriger muss alle
assistenzsysteme hat ausstellen aber das
geht schon
aber für mich ist allrad ein muss
ja die sache schon kurz vorher seine
farben zu triesmann gesagt jetzt schon
der war immer schön kann manuell
der schaltet auch so geil schaltvorgänge
sind geil pelikane du kannst genau du
kannst also einfach auf dem gas bleiben
während dem du auf dem gas bleibst
kannst du direkt schalten und er
wechselt die gänge sehr sehr geschmeidig
das ist das schon da ist
geil ist auch im ersten wir haben als
schlepper momente oder herstellung
besonders hoch ist wenn du da von
gasquets brachte so richtig
das dann schon mehr drin war alex kopf
hin
es gab nach
natürlich eine hecke und heute
das ist eine sehr richtig geil
[Musik]
aber wenn man auf der autobahn ist das
besondere das wenn man dann halt
quasi abbremst und den ländern dieses
gegen gas gibt das ist sehr dynamisch
sein
[Musik]
da war wunderbar
kommen
ja
muss auch was
ja sie jetzt noch nicht sagte van gaal
[Applaus]
wow
mega emotionen neuabschlüsse also
durchaus dass wir jetzt direkt in der
pizzeria simon muss max dax folgt uns
leute wir müssen hier einmal erzielen
es ist geil mit den anstellte ist direkt
scharf direkt auch sehr schönes lenker
alcantara alles paletti alles dabei
aber ist so generell also fährst du
gerne schnell oder ich hab damals hat
sich somit 1920 mein erstes auto mit 180
ps damals bekommen hatte also man erst
hatte 100 augen gar nichts 280
turbodiesel und da bin ich sehr sehr
viel sehr lange und sehr schnell
gefahren 230 240 jetzt sehr hat unsere
hat die 370 und da fahre ich voll
entspannt im kopf als er immer
langstrecke schnell machen müssen dann
180 aber auch nicht mehr auf dauer ja
ich muss sagen bei mir sachen also ich
finde es interessant so schnell zu
erwarten
ich fühle mich da und ich denke dann
wirklich mittlerweile so haben meine
geschwister meine eltern ich denke was
soll's denn also nur risiko bringt ja
nix mehr geil geil geil geil geil geil
diese launch control braucht ist einfach
so anders
das ist einfach hier rein genau dafür
sind wir da wo wir angefangen haben mag
ja nie
mega hat spaß gemacht mega richtig
richtig froh dass hier gelingt bekommen
geil danke das freut mich kommen wir
damit zu bewerten leute ich habe mich
nach reiflicher überlegung dazu
entschieden dass ich mal ein
bewertungssystem von maximal 5 und 5
punkten auf maximal 10 von 10 hoch stufe
und die bisherigen beiden autos um
rechner einfach damit ich noch die
feinere unterschiede zwischen den autos
besser herausarbeiten kann ihr seht ihr
jetzt einmal eingeblendet die alten und
die neuen werte für lukas 911 turbo s
da habe ich einiges aktualisiert und
hin- und hergerechnet und er kommt jetzt
auf insgesamt 42 von 60 punkten wenn
euch das in ruhe anschauen wollte halt
einfach das video an und macht ihr
kurzstopp bei dx auto habe ich auch
einige korrekturen vorgenommen er kommt
mit diesen korrekturen insbesondere im
preis leistungs fällt er sich verbessert
auf 40 von 60 punkten insgesamt und
jetzt sollte kommen wir zum auto von mag
es war wirklich nice leute fangen wir an
mit dem aussehen wie ich schon gesagt
habe ist ein richtiger lachs richtige
freunde sehr schönes auto ich würde es
aber nicht auf einer stufe mit lukas
turbo s stellen daher geht zweimal
aussehen 8 von 10 punkten die
beschleunigung ist richtig geil kicker
uns machen mega spaß aber sie ist
einfach nicht auf dem brachialen
vom turbo s deswegen gibt es hier acht
von zehn in puncto cool das was man
sagen der ist einfach wieder der porsche
effekt der nämlich ketsch das auto ist
richtig sexy es ist cool für mich stets
wie gesagt dafür dass man es im
lebengeschäft deswegen kann ich da nun
hohen wert geben acht von zehn die
praktikabilität also wie praktisch das
auto ist erwartungsgemäß etwas mager
hier gibt es vier von zehn punkten
kleiner kofferraum relativ hoher
verbrauch auch hier wenn auch nicht so
hoch wie beim turbo s das preis
leistungsverhältnis an diesem wagen
finde ich richtig spannend mag hat den
wagen nämlich circa ein jahr alt gekauft
und habe dadurch fast gar keinen wert
wird bzw einen sehr geringen wertverlust
weder den später wieder verkaufen sollte
das hat für diese spezielle art und
weise des kaufs die ihr zu dem auto dazu
gehört bei marx in verbindung mit der
tatsache dass auch der carrera 4 gts
einfach ein absoluter allzweckwaffe und
ein geiler spagat zwischen sportlichkeit
und alltagstauglichkeit in dieser
kategorie 7 von 10 punkten begründet
beim komfort geht auch hier der porsche
ist unfassbar komfortabel für seine
sportlichkeit und für die giftigkeit die
an den tag legen kann wenn man möchte es
ist wirklich beeindruckend aber
insgesamt gehört er nicht zu den
wirklich super komfortablen autos
deswegen gibt es hier 5 und 10 insgesamt
kommen damit auf einen wert von 40 von
60 punkten genauso viele dates tesla und
zwei punkte weniger als lukas turbo s
und ich bin sehr gespannt auf die
nächsten autos im laufe dieser woche
werden top videos markt kommen leute
viel spaß und bis zum nächsten mal